today we're going to try to answer three
questions what makes software not fun
where does it hurt us and can we make it
fun so to do this we're gonna explore
five topics the punchline of the
presentation is gonna be as you've heard
me before test-driven development to
kind of feel better and faster
development but it's kind of hard to
just do TDD you know unless you put some
conditions in place that will help you
out to be successful at it right and one
of them is operating in an architecture
that is conducive to doing test-driven
development but also kind of yields much
more flexibility in your applications so
we're gonna explore some architectures
we're going to look at object-oriented
programming for by and large if we work
in PHP we tend to operate in the opie
paradigm so we're gonna a little bit
look at that kind of how to play to opie
strengths ahead of that we're gonna look
in a broader spectrum kind of what are
enablers of better code and I touch on
some of them yesterday but we're gonna
dig a little bit deeper into paradigms
and the first thing we're going to look
at right now is the effect of bat bat
code on your phone so is anybody
familiar with Roberts e-marketing Uncle
Bob okay all right cool yeah so he
famously said this right it will be a
long time before I trust software to
drive a car I am in because I know all
right he knows how bats African can get
and if you remember Samantha's keynote
right she touched on some of the bad
effects of bad software on you know
human lies right we're starting to see a
lot of software in cars these days it's
scary how much software dries cars right
Tesla is pretty famous you know for
putting a lot of advanced software in
their cars right they're doing some
really really interesting things of
course
you know what could possibly go wrong I
don't maybe this right so beside that
dramatic effect in general you know what
takes away our fun in software of course
you've got inheriting somebody else's
code that's rarely ever fun having a
hard time understanding how the system
works right if you can't understand the
code that you inherited from somebody
else it's gonna be even harder to
understand what the system does it's
never fun to also be breaking new things
not breaking old things when we build
new things and yeah and we hate testing
okay I mean it's just who wants to do
that
so now that we look at a little bit some
of the pain points of bad code let's
look at some enablers for better code
and so like I said I touched on these
yesterday a little bit so I like to look
at three things to kind of promote
better code you could put all this under
clean code but I like to kind of
separate things out a little bit because
it kind of helps me focus my learning
basically so I like to look at
test-driven development patterns and
principles like the solid principles and
all these things and then clean code as
defined by code that is self documenting
you know you read it it reads like
English it's really easy to reason about
so for TDD we're gonna touch on that at
the end of the presentation we're gonna
kind of build up toward that for clean
code that could be a talk all of its own
but instead I'm gonna refer you to
Robert Martin's book you've probably
already seen it and now let's look at
patterns right so that's why I didn't
get to dig into yesterday but so if you
look at most programming languages
that we work with they support more than
just one paradigm you know you got
object-oriented programming you've got
imperative programming where your system
can have some state you can start
persisting state in variables you know
procedural as a subset of imperative
where you can kind of delegate
functionality to procedures and then you
get functional programming right and and
these days if you look at kind of the
way most complex software is is being
built there's a lot of excitement around
functional and there's all the
excitement around Opie so I always want
to be inclusive of all paradigms I think
the the key thing whatever paradigm that
you work with you know whatever language
that you work with you should try to
understand which paradigms it supports
how well it supports those paradigms and
then try to find best practices and
patterns that play to the strengths of
those paradigms and because in the end
the whole purpose of patterns is to
simplify the complexity of a system
right it's you know I'll see our people
diss on Opie but they're not really
truly adopting Opie practices right they
you know validate the law of Demeter
they do you know they leak too much
information from objects they don't do
the tail don't ask kind of policy so if
you work in functional try to find
functional patterns right so here I'm
gonna give you a link to the slot to
these slides but I have a link to
functional programming patterns it is a
talk by Scott lation who runs the
website f-sharp for fun and profit I
highly recommend it he's got a really a
lot of really interesting patterns on
functional programming um he's applying
them to f-sharp but they're applicable
to functional programming programming in
general
and as far as Opie goes you know for
some time we've had this solid
principles the Gang of Four design
patterns the you know Martin Fowler's
enterprise application patterns so these
are more biased toward object-oriented
programming with and usually with a type
system and it works really well with
with PHP right in with PHP we can apply
all these patterns so I have some links
here I don't if you've ever seen design
patterns PHP read the docs dot io great
resource it has all the angle for design
patterns explained with concrete
examples in PHP so it's a great
reference I look at it you know all the
time whenever I'm trying to solve a
problem yeah I'm pretty sure there's
probably a pattern for that so I kind of
go back to it and if you're interested
in functional programming functional
programming like I said Scott lashings
talk here that's a link to it if you've
ever worked with Java when they
implemented streams it makes it made
things very interesting so I have a link
to that I have another link to use cases
for functional programming by Robert
Martin and I have another link to on
genomic heals talk on intro to
functional priming with programming
which is also very excellent so to get
back to object-oriented programming with
my team I'll I looked at kind of what
patterns we use ranked from most often
to kind of least often so p0 we use it
all the time right p4 yeah every once in
awhile so you know dependency injection
you know all of these we tend to use
them pretty often and so I'd be
interested you know to hear from you
guys what kind of patterns you guys come
across in your applications I think it's
always interesting to see how people
solve problems
so this was patterns they matter so we
just looked at enablers for better coat
test-driven development which we're
going to get back to the clean code to
book and then we just kind of looked at
references to kind of learn more about
patterns and how to apply them but I
want to drill down a little bit more
with object-oriented programming because
there's this thing that I feel that we
do very often which is kind of flaccid
Opie will create classes will
instantiate classes almost anywhere in
our system and then we can't we kind of
end up with something like this where we
have a lot of components that live in
different classes and it got more
components and they all call one another
and then we end up with like a lot of
tight couplings it makes things very
difficult to test but also what often
happen is if we change one thing because
of all of these tight couplings and
those dependencies will will tend to
break a lot of things if we change
anything in the system right that's not
what we want you know obviously we want
to achieve a simple maintainable system
and to do that we want to have loosely
coupled components so we can also show a
consistent dependency graph and a way to
achieve all this that's what design
patterns are for right so now if you get
back to that large system and you have
all these components working together
now they're all nicely isolated right
they're not kind of intertwined together
so now it's a lot easier to change
something without breaking everything
right so out of high-level I just kind
of want you guys to kind of keep this
mental picture
all right so that was for Opie so then
let's get into web application
architectures because because this
concept of decoupling things is going to
be relevant in the architectures that we
operate it so everybody is very familiar
with MVC right that's anytime we build a
web something we tend to use some kind
of mu C framework and kind of operate
within this this paradigm and it's you
know in my experience I've found it
useful as long as there's a very close
correlation of every uri with whatever
database table that you're trying to
modify right so if you're trying to edit
a user okay that's fine if you're doing
one crud operation forgiving URI then
things work pretty well with MVC but in
my experience it tends to not be the
reality of most applications that I
build it tends to have they tend to have
a lot more complex business logic and
that's the thing you know in many times
applications may start out just as being
simple crud to the database you know
create read update delete crud and they
start very simple but then they get more
complex they get a lot more business
logic and that's the thing is you want
to have a layer for the business logic
you don't want to put all your business
logic into controllers because the
controller is very much tied to the URL
to HTTP it it just doesn't quite fit
well in the controller so then people
are like okay well let's put it all on
the models but ok your models are also
responsible for getting data in and out
of your data store do you also want to
overload them with you know business
logic in there and so in the end we
don't have to confine ourselves to those
three layers and B and C you know we can
create classes as many as we want but so
4 we're gonna come back to that now
let's look a framework coupling
because what often happens when we work
in laravel or you know Symphony or help
me take 2.5 you know what we tend to
write our code in a way that's a pretty
tightly coupled to the framework you
know to the frameworks middleware
upstream you know the the controllers
and then downstream to the frameworks
data persistence layer right we tend to
have everything just kind of very
intertwined together and it makes things
definitely harder to test because
everything is it's coupled to the
framework now in an ideal world and
actually in practice it is perfectly
possible to leverage everything that
your framework has to offer without
coupling your business logic to it
completely right you should be able to
always have a clean isolation layer
between your business logic and your
framework it's just that when you work
when you look at a symphony tutorial or
a laravel tutorial they're going to show
you you know extend our base controller
and then create your method and then put
your all your business logic there and
then you're done right that's kind of
where they show you but you know we're
also our own free thinking people right
we can make our own decisions so and we
should so to address these challenges
we've arrived at this architecture which
really is are just a collection of
patterns taken from Fowler's enterprise
patterns really I mean it's pretty
simple I'm sure you've all worked and
something similar or seen something
similar but the goal here is to keep the
views and the controller's you know the
views and the controllers are very much
going to be coupled to your framework
and we're going to keep them at arm's
length so then in this green box we're
gonna have command services repositories
you know entities may be data transfer
objects
and if you look at everything in this
green zone that's basically your
business right and everything in this
business in this business layer is
pretty much framework agnostic right you
could take all this code that maybe in
laravel today and then just put it in
symphony and it shouldn't take you too
much time to do that so the goal is to
keep the controller is really really
thin a controller should do very little
more than just extract some data from
the HTTP request from the session and
hand that over to either a command or
service but but the key here is anything
that's in a green zone does not care
about the transport layer right you
should not be invoking any kind of HTTP
construct inside of the green zone
you should be passing primitives into it
or objects into it so your services you
could think of your services as to keep
the high level capabilities of your
business it could be the closest thing
to your API that you could think of
right in my experience the commend layer
I don't always put it in there right
command classes are very small classes
that interact with one or more services
and the name of a command class reads
almost like the use case add feedback to
user add comment to the feedback to the
user right there they're very specific
class names so in a project you may have
dozens of services if you have dozens of
services you may end up with 40 50 60
command classes for example right and
those those command classes capture all
the use cases of your system the
repositories
and what we do in there is just it's the
basically work with the data layer so in
in my experience what we're doing is
we've been using doctrine ORM we will
inject doctrine ORM as a dependency to
the repository
we also put clean interfaces between our
architectural layer right you'll see an
interface between the command and the
services and you'll see an interface
between the service and the repositories
right so if I want to fake out if I want
to put a test double between
architectural layers my test layer it's
not a big deal it's very easy to do
right so but the nice thing about the
repository pattern is that if you wanted
to you could implement polyglot polyglot
persistence you know right now you hear
a lot of debate about you know sequel
vs. no sequel document stores versus
relational databases you know in the end
and there are very valid use cases for
both I don't subscribe to the idea of we
should be using no sequel for everything
at the same time I do see some really
good uses for it
in the end the right architecture should
allow you to be flexible enough to
change your mind about what your
persistence layer should be and even
have multiple types of persistence
layers in your in your application right
and the repository pattern kind of makes
that easy you could have some
repositories into which you inject an
object relational mapper like the entity
measure from doctrine and some of the
repositories where you inject a object
document mapper so doctrine also has a
no DM right so this architecture has
worked really well for us and it's given
us it's made it's made test-driven
development a lot easier because we can
very easily test drive our repositories
very easily test drive
our services and commends as well they
have a clean separation between the
layers I have nice interfaces between
them so it makes everything a lot
simpler so here I have a link to
polyglot persistence so I'll show you
how to get the slides on the join then
you'll be able to download the slides so
these slides just kind of go over what I
just talked about if you're interested
in learning more about clean
architectures I have a link to an
article and a link to video both by
Robert Martin on the on the subject
alright so we just looked at application
architectures so now that we've got a
slight kind of better an understanding
of architectures that promote decoupling
and we understand with opie kind of how
to work decoupling and the way we think
about Opie it's gonna help us with
test-driven development and here I'm
saying better fuels faster what I'm
trying to dispel is this thinking that
doing test-driven development
automatically makes you slower I'd like
to show that it can actually help you
ship things faster because you're doing
a lot less clicking around and we're
gonna look at some of that overhead so
yesterday I had a whole talk on why you
know do TDD but to kind of sum up that
you know that talk I'm gonna I'm going
to touch on speed but the the key point
would be to of my talk as they was about
being able to embrace change whether its
new requirements new features but to
also be able to constantly improve our
code right because that's the need that
we feel but we're always scared of
improving our code because we're always
scared of breaking things
we're doing test-driven development that
fear tends to go away so one of the
things I called out yesterday was that
the nice thing about TDD is you may not
start out your system with the optimal
patterns with the cleanest of code you
may kind of compromise on these fronts
but with TDD you can incrementally
improve things without fear so now I
want to look at I want to separate two
things there's unit tests and then
there's test-driven development a lot of
what's being done today is a lot of code
gets written and a lot of code gets
manually tested and then we think okay
well we need to have a regression suite
so we'll go and write some unit tests
after the fact right it's it's not
dramatic it's just not it's a bit
redundant right it's like you've already
written a bunch of code you've already
tested it manually and now you're
replicating the manual testing that
you've been doing with unit tests after
the fact right tests to run different
test driven development is it's
different because you first have to
write a failing test before even writing
some code right so you already have that
anytime you're gonna write code you're
gonna have a mental picture of what your
code should do all TDD asks you to do is
to write down what that mental picture
you have you know what that is what the
expected behavior just kind of write it
down it takes 30 seconds it's really
it's really fast and then you just write
just you just write code to make those
assertions pass so the thing is there
are a lot of TDD tutorials out there on
the web and they're very useful I
encourage you guys to look at them but
they're always for pretty simple
algorithmic problems right it's rarely
you know show you how to build a web
application from scratch or like a web
service
scratch and that's kind of what I'm
trying to solve with this talk and some
of my tutorials as well so because yeah
web applications have several
architectural layers they have a lot of
classes right that kind of depend on one
another and they're also heavily
data-driven right in any time you build
a web app you're gonna be handling a lot
of data so where are some goals I want
to be able to get the satisfaction of
building business functionality within
the comfort of my test harness right I
want to be able to solve all the
business problems inside of my test
harness without kind of having to worry
about the UI or a lot of things that
don't materially impact what my business
logic is so that's something I'd be
interested in so to show you how to get
that done first I want to paint a
picture on where we waste time so any
time if you're not doing test-driven
development any time you build something
one of the first things we'll do is set
up a local database right and probably
add some database tables well we might
use a tool to scaffold a basic user
interface so that we can have something
to start with then finally we get to
write some business logic right that's
the thing we actually care about but
then you know we're gonna use a manual
debugger to step through code because
things don't always work the way we want
and if we're not using a debugger we
might add a bunch of you know print our
statements or use a logging tool to you
know log a lot of be intermediate
behavior through through our code and
yeah we're gonna break things as we
build new things
that's kind of we do that right so we
waste time today while building things
now once we've built things now we're
going to test things so everything
that's in red in my opinion is bad
what's in green that's what we came here
to do kind of right that's business
logic so when we test things you know we
wrote all this code and now we ask
ourselves does that code work okay well
how are we gonna do that we're gonna
probably click on the UI or we're gonna
whip up you know postman to hit our API
endpoint or we might also visually
inspect the database records right so if
you wrote some business logic chances
are it did something to your data so
we're gonna look you know we're gonna go
and sequel Pro and kind of inspect
database records to see that things are
what we expect or sometimes we want to
shortcut all the UI steps that we have
to click so we'll modify some database
records to kind of jump the application
in the state we want right I mean this
some of these things may sound familiar
right sorry I went back in time yeah so
the point I was making is across those
two slides all activities are a mark in
red if you think about it they're kind
of throwaway activities right they're
only relevant once when you do it and
you have to do it repeatedly if you
think about it it's think about how much
time we're wasting today doing all these
things wouldn't be nice if we could
always be coding there you go
testing is for closers I guess we could
say that so if I'm working in a TDD
workflow all I'm ever doing is coding
against assertions so I'm the first
thing I'm going to do is write a failing
test right so I've already jotted down
what I expect my code to do then I'm
just gonna write just a sorry I'm gonna
write just enough code to make that test
pass and then maybe I might refactor
some code right and that's your TDD
workflow now notice how all those red
things that I had pictured on the
previous slides how they're not here
right and a TDD workflow you can operate
in that and now if you think about it
you can start moving really really fast
you can start solving business problems
really fast and that's this thing these
activities in green they're foundational
activities they're always relevant
because every time you build something
new you've got a test written out for it
and it's got your back
it's that test always answers that
question for you of doesn't my code work
so this is where things get interesting
we want to introduce meaningful data
into our tests because that's another
thing I mentioned about the challenges
of web web applications development is
we do a lot with data how do we make
that happen was anybody at David
Letterman talk earlier this morning when
he did coupling your tests to your
production code okay yeah that was a
great talk it kind of touches on very
similar topics so
here's what we did to make it work so
picture 2x unit test harness so PHP unit
write an ORM that lives inside of the
inside of PHP unit and then in memory
database so now imagine your RM instead
of your test harness backed by an
in-memory database and David in his talk
he touched a little bit on that earlier
right so then we start writing every
unit test on top of this and the way we
achieve this was by using PHP unit using
the doctrine or RM back by sequel light
does anybody here use symphony alright
cool
yeah Symphony it's very trivial right in
the config file you can in the test
config file you can tell it use PDO
sequel light and there you go
so before we dig into the workflow I
kind of want to clarify a few things
some things that we want to avoid when
we work with test-driven development we
want to avoid less than 100 percent
coverage sure there may be exceptions
and that's fine I'm saying we want to
avoid it
in my experience we've been able to do
it on a code base where we have well we
have almost 3,000 tests and the 100%
cover our source directory so it's it's
doable right but you know your
priorities may defer but typically if
you go below 100% code coverage it means
that somebody wrote some code that was
not there to satisfy to satisfy our test
which means somebody isn't technically
doing test-driven development it's not
the end of the world you know sometimes
we catch ourselves and we you know we
fix it it's not that big of a deal but
it's an interesting signal now the other
thing about code coverage is it's not a
silver bullet
okay because it is absolutely possible
to have one hard percent cook coverage
and actually test nothing because you
can call your code but you could have no
meaningful assertion against it right
just say assert true equals true and
okay you just call your code and you're
not checking for any behavior right so
you know take code coverage with a grain
of salt
and this is why code reviews are very
important so sure we're going to use
tooling to to measure the code coverage
that's fine but what really matters are
peer code reviews one of the most
effective thing that a code reviewer can
do is to look at the test and ensure and
ensure that that they can understand the
tests and verify that the tests actually
are relevant to the business
requirements that we're trying to
implement to whichever user story where
we're trying to implement right that's
the most impactful thing that a code
reviewer can do okay so with these
things in mind now let's look a little
bit of a TDD workflow so we looked at
this architecture I've seen TDD being
done in all kinds of different ways what
I care about really is this purple box
the business logic right and if you
think about it upstream of the business
logic you have your controller you get
your routes you get your UI and then
below that you've got your migrations
you've got your database schema and
that's it yeah so now you have all those
intertwined concerns and it is possible
to do test-driven development more in an
acceptance way where you're kind of
doing it full stack I don't like doing
that because it's just it just takes way
too much time right where you do TDD all
the way from the UI you know all the way
to the database right I like to keep
things more the unit level but some
people do that
and in my experience it makes for a lot
less productive TDD so what I like to do
is kind of separate things out right put
my business logic and its own little box
up there and then I do not worry about
migrations I do not worry about the UI
my routes and my controller right I
solve all my business problems on its
own by tidying my entities my
repositories my services in rapid
iterations but I'm just kind of working
with these within these architectural
layers more at the unit level cool so
once I have solved a number of business
problems at some point I do want to test
things full-stack right I don't want to
just you know ship and pray that it
works right I actually you want to test
everything so I'm gonna lean on my RM in
our case doctrine to automatically
generate migrations from my entity graph
and that's kind of the beautiful thing
about doctrine is you can have all of
your entities already coded out with all
of your annotations and when you run
doctrine diff it'll look at your my
sequel connection and look at your
differences and automatically generate
the necessary migrations to bring your
database in sync with what yours your
entity graph is so once I've done that
and then okay then I can start hooking
my controllers and my routes and my UI
to it and then I can do some manual
testing right but the the key here is
I'm not worrying about these things at
the bottom of the screen constantly
right I'm not constantly doing these
things at the bottom of the screen I
just kind of do it once in a while once
I've already solved a bunch of problems
so the workflow now looks like this I
might first
TDD my repository TDD my service that
uses reposed
I kind of repeat meanwhile I could have
somebody else on the team build a UI
could concurrently they don't have to
worry about my business logic just yet
and then I TV more services and finally
I'll map the URI create the migrations
run them and then test application to do
you test yeah but application to do yah
but what matters here is that think of
it as zone 1 and zone 2 and they are
decoupled so there you go so I have an
example of a ride hailing application so
this is a guitar that I've done okay
this is a guitar that I've done and I
have videos on my youtube channel
I'll have links to that and the goal was
to have a repeatable exercise that is of
something not trivial so I did that so I
have this is my app test case class all
of my all of my unit tests extend from
that class and the first thing I do is I
get the ORM and at the top line I get
the ORM and so then I can pass it to my
repositories and then at the bottom is
set up Anthony measure this is what
kills the scheme the schema and rebuilds
it for every single test the nice thing
now is that in my repositories when I
test drive I can actually test drive my
repositories with let's say dql strings
to retrieve data and I'm actually
testing this functionality for real in
memory so it it makes things a lot
faster so this is the first test the
first thing I want to do at the top left
you can see test create and save user
once I can create a user than
I'm going to assign the driver role to
the user I'm going to write another test
to assign a driver role then then I'll
do another test to assign passenger role
and as I go I'm refactoring my tests to
reuse things that I've done in my
previous tests all right here I make
sure that a user can have both roles I
also have a test to make sure that if
you're trying to assign the same role to
the same user it will throw an exception
so that was for the repositories now had
the services that use the repositories
so you'll be able to see all this code
online not going to bore you too much
with it
so the finished service test is on the
left and the service class is on the
right and here's the finished repository
so this one is a bit longer so that's
just a repository and then here's my
user entity so here you can see all of
my orang mappings and again they work
I'm able to verify that those mappings
work inside of my test harness inside of
PHP unit by using doctrine with sequel
Lite instead of the test harness so
that's the role entity here you go
so next step create the migration files
create your routes deploy the code win
so yeah if you want to see it in action
TDD vids on bitly I have like seven
hours of videos me kind of building this
thing out so and all my code is on
github so you can look at the master
branch and kind of have fun with it so
boom okay all right I got some more
reading also on those slides some more
articles about Uncle Bob xunit patterns
calm by Jeremy sorrows which also
there's a book that was written that's
kinda has the same content as the site I
like the site because it's hyperlinked
so it's really easy to reference things
if you're interested in working with
legacy code and kind of had a wedge unit
test and your legacy code
Martin Fowler has a great book about it
but I prefer Michael feathers book about
it but they're both really good
resources so boom alright so yeah some
benefits you know you can keep things
decoupled you don't have to worry about
your UI when you work on your business
or vice versa you can stay in the
getting the zone stay in it
it's a lot easier to stay in the zone
when you do test-driven development and
if your boss distracts you you can it's
a lot easier to get back to it because
you can look at your last test so and
yeah you don't need to worry about
optimal design right away that's nothing
about TDD everything can be very
incremental right you just implement
first optimize later you're not afraid
to do it later on because you get your
tests and you get all these things
alright so that was TDD the case I try
to make here is that TDD helps fuel
faster development by doing a lot less
redundant things so it's really you know
I'm trying to show that you know we
shouldn't try to pit better against
faster it is possible to have better
fuel faster development and become more
agile in the process and have a lot more
fun so we can do a lot less of crawling
through reverb crafts sorry I kind of
reuse my meme from yesterday but there's
that
and do a lot more of better software by
applying all these three things and have
better software at the center of your
agile stack that was kind of a topic I
covered yesterday so you can have
constantly increasing business value
because you can constantly release new
features kind of at a sustained pace and
again sorry I reuse that mean from
yesterday as well so that's it I'm not
going to hold you back for questions
I'll be here you can always come to me
with questions I want to let everybody
go to lunch so oh yeah
loose message announcement from puss and
boots if you guys can be kind enough to
give me some feedback here
that's they'll be the most effective way
for me to improve this for future
generations so thank you all for your
time appreciate it
[Applause]